[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cept for every
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it begins on a dark I look at this
[Music]
you're not gonna find another girl like
her in a million years
[Music]
it's also magical London I've never
before
that first someday a blender to say
[Music]
I've never before
that fast someday
[Music]
[Music]
I read way
[Music]
I am NOT going back I ran away and I am
NOT going back
let's make some magic
[Music]
- you're a fraud
[Music]
and octopod
ha
there's this girl
[Music]
it's not time in my life I ran away
I am NOT going back and I am NOT going
back I ran away and I am NOT going back
I am NOT going
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
husband
[Music]
Gerard
[Music]
get in here
oh sure
[Music]
oh sure
I've never
[Music]
Russell goodbye thank you goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after all enough enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well this is it folks the big event this
evening one man will attempt to recreate
the suicide of noted pedophile Jeffrey
Edward Epstein it will certainly be a
feat like nothing the world has ever
seen and could only be attempted by the
undisputed superstar of Daredevils
Steven can even Crowder
good evening I'm audio Wade we are here
for an attempt at what is no doubt one
of the most anticipated fake suicide
recreations in history if you're
tweeting about this evening and Lord in
heaven I hope you are be sure to use the
hashtag Epstein didn't kill himself and
please be certain to tweet your
questions or comments to s Crowder which
we will read live later in the program
just prior to the stunts being performed
and tonight through Black Friday if you
join up at louder with Crowder calm /
mug club with promo code Epstein you'll
get $20 off again that's louder with
Crowder calm / mug club promo code
Epstein $20 off your subscription now a
lot went into this evening and we have
here Steven himself to give us a closer
look Steven tell the folks at home what
they can expect to see tonight yeah
thanks for audio way to appreciate you
doing a bang-up job first let me be
clear there about one in a million
details that we cannot go over or
account for in this experiment but let
me be the first to say or let me say
this first on the outset the number that
we are trying to hit on that was a new
Tama tur scale my engineer is not here
with me right now it's 55 kilograms 121
pounds of force 55 kilograms 121 pounds
of force is what we're looking to hit to
recreate a scenario in which Jeffrey
Epstein suicide is even plausible it was
even even remotely possible that's the
low end keep in mind the story that
we've been told is you know from the New
York Times Washington Post is that
Jeffrey Epstein knelt toward the floor
with enough force that he broke several
bones in his neck on a rope that he
fashioned himself from from orange
bedsheets some people thought the
bedsheets were paper that's not true
apparently they were actually real
bedsheets and keep in mind too something
that a lot of people may not know that
when administering death by hanging the
number to ensure death that has always
been used historically is a thousand to
twelve hundred and fifty foot pounds of
force now why aren't you using that
receival I'm gonna I'm gonna get to that
in just a second and isn't there
something about the hyoid bone yeah I'm
glad that you brought that up many in
the media they've tried to paint kind of
people who are even remotely skeptical
of the epstein suicide as conspiracy
theorists and they often point to the
high way bone claiming that Jeffrey
Epstein fractured that bone it only
requires 35 pounds of force to fracture
and of course that makes it seem as
though it's very easy very plausible the
most likely scenario that Jeffrey
Epstein hung and killed himself I
believe it's a red herring for several
reasons couldn't be less relevant it
couldn't be less relevant to this for
one the measurement being cited that
people are often using this was in a
laboratory where they took a hide from a
cadaver and put it into a vise right
that's not the same as a real-world
scenario where you've got cartilage and
tissue and neck fat as I will know then
number two most importantly Jeffrey
Epstein had three fractures in his neck
and you will see us trying to recreate
that here in a second three fractures
including thyroid cartilage which is
much more difficult to fracture than the
hyoid bone so let me kind of paint a
scenario if you get into a car wreck
right you get you get jostled around and
you break your pinkie you break your
wrist but you also break your femur
I can't just recreate a scenario where I
break a pinkie and say well let's go
down for me call it a day we need to
recreate a scenario in which the most
severe fracture is accounted for and
that is what we are trying to do this
evening mimicking the force that will be
required to create all three fat
fractures that were found in the suicide
oh boy this all sounds very dangerous
Stephen I to the untrained eye yeah well
I don't think it will exactly tickle
nasty
I didn't say did you say what tickle I
didn't say what tickle I just said it's
dangerous but you know I'm fine doing it
that's what I do I don't think you could
pull this off it's also important to
note only 8% of victims by the way
victims of hanging suicide are found
with with broken hyoid bones keep in
mind that these are suicides by hanging
they typically aren't kneeling right
it's usually their Brooking themselves
like in Shawshank knocking the stool out
and hanging from a beam in the ceiling
it's dead I'm familiar it's a great film
and by the way very similar tonight now
we're gonna be crawling through miles of
[ __ ] just to make this happen for you so
please use the promo code and get your
$20 off mug club so this will all be
worth it earn this something else that
we need to
keep in mind as well 8% have a fractured
hyoid bone when you go to the situation
the statistics of people who have three
fractures that we saw in Jeffrey Epstein
suicide that number drops to one in
twenty only one in twenty from dead hang
suicides result in these three factors
and how often is that kind of fracture
found in homicides thirty-four percent
yeah so one could argue that these kind
of fractures are more likely to occur in
a homicide than in a suicide is that
correct yeah yeah however though when we
discussed this stunt with an engineer as
you well know we've had engineers here
helping with this project wanting to be
as fair-minded as possible after
reviewing multiple studies he came to
the conclusion that a real-world
scenario like we've created right here
in that scenario about 121 pounds or 55
kilograms are what would be required at
minimum to result in the three fractures
sustained by mr. Epstein so we're aiming
to achieve a far lower number than even
necessary to ensure death by hanging
because we want to be as fair-minded as
possible and take the lowest number the
lowest barrier to entry because we don't
know we don't know how any of it is
gonna turn out and I want the folks at
home to understand that this stunt is
not something that should be tried at
home you are in fact an untrained
professional Steven I understand that
you've gone to great lengths to prepare
for this evening including the
incorporation of some unconventional
training methods yeah that's true I mean
the unconventional for most maybe not
for me I've been working with personal
trainers for a long time from Hollywood
someone who have worked with he's
trained to work with Chris Hemsworth's
and in Chris Evans
although Chris's and I've been training
for a long time and I don't take these
things lightly
certainly not these stunts and we've
been strengthening what we need to
strengthen and trying to close up any
holes in my in my professional stunt
stuntman game and I think we've done
that and I believe we have some footage
of that now
when I train it's a preparation of my
mind as much as my body I trained for
unlimited power absolute endurance
bottomless stamina unmeasured grit this
is about unleashing the power of the
truth mastering the fear shaping your
destiny strengthening the neck through
the process of mastering one's fear one
masters one self today I will test the
limits of the human body of the human
mind and above all primarily the neck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you master your fears
you master yourself
and all this is just as much preparation
for my body because my mind 90% of it
100% mental I truly am standing before a
champion I also understand that you've
been on a very strict diet Stephen is
that correct that is correct yeah you do
your homework audio wait it's been
pretty much nothing but waster crackers
and in actual oyster nothing else of
course in a stunt like this there is a
lot that could go wrong what are you
most worried about tonight sir well you
know um you'd think that I'd be more
worried and hanging myself than I am but
gee Morgan Jr left a bottle of half a
bottle of tramadol and we have someone
on watch for the clinton so I actually
feel I you know I feel pretty good about
it I really do and certainly good to
hear something else very important to
consider is that reports show that
Jeffrey Epstein in fact hung himself
from a rope of bedsheets that he
fashioned from tearing and tying himself
which is notable considering the lack of
any tools or sharp edges in his cell in
order to estimate how long this would
take and subsequently determining how
long the security cameras would have had
to function for this elaborate suicide
to go unnoticed
we have even Brendan's standing by to
begin fashioning a rope live as we speak
Brendan if that isn't your definition of
riveting broadcasting throw out your
dictionary and may Christ himself have
mercy on your hellbound soul with an
event like this security is always a
concern that's why we've put one of our
guards on full-time Clinton watch
officer given how do things look out
there
[Music]
you truly can never be too safe now
along with safety a huge concern of this
team's is accuracy our field reporter
Tom Finnegan spoke earlier with Stephen
can evens technical adviser quarterblack
Garrett well we're here with technical
supervisor quarterblack Garrett and
what's going on here today so we got an
a by a recreation of the cell that
Jeffrey Epstein was sleeping in at the
time of his not suicide this year is a
bunk it's to recreate the bunk walls
here the painted gray to reprove you
know the great this prison so also right
over here if you look over here this the
bed sheet and that bed she's going to be
connected to mr. stand evil his Nick
right this this apparatus here is going
to be what we're using to measure the
force on his neck it's going to be
measured in kilograms we're looking for
55 total to break his neck we have a
backup here measuring the tension on the
rope here is a diameter yeah and we're
looking for 55 total to break his neck
and then right below that that's the
suicide zone all right
suicide zone that's where he's gonna
recreate he's gonna get on his knees and
he's gonna lean right into the suicide
just to recreate exactly specifically
the events leading up to Jeffrey Epstein
suicide and who was that he's the guy
this broadcast promises to be a learning
experience for all of us Steven you've
mentioned the training went into this
evening but that's not all the
precautions this team has taken correct
no no I really want people to understand
that there's a whole team that makes
this happen behind the scenes you know
and I don't want to take all of the
glory for that they've worked tirelessly
in earlier this week they actually did a
dry run with a test subject and I think
I think we have some footage of that
[Music]
and since then I understand you've
worked out some kinks dear god I hope so
yeah one unknown that must be accounted
for in an event like this is the weather
earlier this evening half-asian lawyer
bill Richman took a look and made
certain that this stunt would not be
derailed here we have his report
well as you can see we've got a slight
overcast here during the day which will
burn off towards the evening is so we
fluctuate between 50 and 60% humidity
with only a bare whisper of wind
throughout the day at no more than one
mile per hour we're not expecting any
precipitation as a result I'd say we're
have a near picture-perfect November
evening for doing stunts
which as you know is completely
irrelevant since we'll be filming inside
of an air-conditioned studio now Stephen
that seems almost to have been totally
unnecessary you know what seems so until
you understand that we have to put them
on retainer and we try to get our
money's worth so thanks affirmation bill
no I understand
with a monster like Epstein it's easy to
believe that all America rejoiced at his
demise but sometimes we forget the
victims of all this real folks upon whom
Epstein's predatory nature inflicted a
living hell Tom Finnegan has spoken to
those who have been negatively affected
by Epstein's death here is what he heard
there was a good man a real facilitator
made my life a hell of a lot simpler
anytime I needed to escape the wife I'd
call Jeffy boy and he'd fly me out of
the island that's great that's made my
life immeasurably more difficult finding
young girls tough sex was a damn shame a
damn shame is what this is a year ago we
were all on top of the world then
suddenly it all came crashing down like
a house of cards pulled over by a yappy
young man crying shame
an absolute tragedy murder plain and
simple folks that's what it was sexy
teenager adjacent murder I tried to stop
her I said to her Hilary don't go
suicide and my friend now you hear but
she didn't listen
very sad there you have it folks as they
say we never fully know how our actions
are affecting others right Steven yeah
sometimes it's tough to know how it
affects real folks out in the real world
and it's it's heartbreaking truer words
perhaps never spoken I believe it is
time for you to head back and get ready
before the stunts so go ahead and be
safe thank you thank you very much Audio
wait I appreciate it
thank you it's got speed for me is it we
go here
just yeah yeah I'll go you can I'm gonna
go this way that's that's perfect
earlier today Tom Finnegan spoke with
someone with a special insight into
Epstein here's that interview now yes
I'm here with someone who knew Jeffrey
Epstein who could be considered a
confidante he is this many Timmy thank
you for being here hi happy to be here
and what are your initial thoughts on
the suicide of Jeffrey Epstein I like
the orange bedsheets yes the orange
bedsheets and do you in fact think he
did kill himself I saw Santa Claus at
the mall
yes there you have it he saw Santa at
the mall back to you ladies and
gentlemen we are moments away from the
attempt by Steven can even to recreate
the suicide of Jeffrey Epstein but first
we will have a quick word from our
sponsors and remember folks please for
the love of everything holy and just
tweet using the hashtag Epstein didn't
kill himself and visit louder with
Crowder dot-com slash mug club use promo
code Epstein for $20 off we will return
in a moment with the daredevil himself
Steven can even answering your tweets
live
[Music]
there's definitely a racist history of
Thanksgiving it's genocide on holiday
Thanksgiving lies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
now I know what you're thinking did he
fire 14 rounds or 15
that's erroneous as my new all steel PP
q5 match as a 17 round magazine plus one
in the chamber with the best ergonomics
in the business I'm capable of putting a
shot right between your eyes at 40 yards
away so you have to ask yourself one
question do you feel lucky well do ya
punkk lighter with prouder studios
protected exclusively by Walther what's
your home defense plan when it comes to
safety there's no substitute for a
quality firearm and if you're a gun
owner there's no replacement for
firearms legal protection firearms legal
protection provides lawful gun owners an
uncapped legal defense program 24/7
emergency hotline access to a network of
over 2,500 experienced attorneys legal
education on firearm laws in your state
via our mobile app and plans to protect
you every step of the way if you are
involved in a self-defense entity the
firearms legal comm /lw see today
everyone whistle blower 22 here you may
know that Joe Biden was recently seen
with a blood-filled left eye during a
climate town law to ignore me this is
just more proof of this actual baby
boomer is too old to support a closed
circulatory system that's true more
important truthful here is that this
answers the reptilian question
this artist on pole pointed out the
similarities between Joe Biden and my
home lizard with this disgusting ability
to squirt blood for the time
Uncle Joe must have felt threatened by
so many questions and just couldn't
suppress his natural instincts I
shouldn't even have to mention the other
obvious similarity of their little
creepy Joe shares with a horny lizard
thanks for watching
if you want to support me and pledged to
my GoFundMe and help my command center
moved to a better space to make videos
apparently I can only work on videos at
night while my mom's asleep until next
time listen we're out live and I believe
we have some tweets here let's take a
look at okay here we have s Crowder I
wish Stephen was a victim of pedophile
Island I guess I'll have to settle for
him hanging himself on camera your
response was just very good this is what
happens when you do a live broadcast
audio wait I'm not at all surprised
honestly I wish I could say that I was
and you know what it's actually not
called pedophile Island okay we were the
ones who sort of coined that that's not
the official name so just you know water
off a duck's back
understood and we have the next week
nobody here no okay read there here we
have Jaime I told my dad about how s
Crowder was going to try to kill himself
on live stream on live stream like how
Epstein did and my dad told me to tell
Steven like read Foreman would say
you're a dumbass well unless she's
saying that her dad actually is read
Foreman I don't really care all that
much because his opinion doesn't mean a
whole lot to me we have engineers here
we have a nurse here on staff and I feel
pretty confident about what we're
looking to achieve so you know Jamie can
you go fornicate yourself well said
next week steven crowder I am very hard
right now
your thoughts that's his problem not
mine
good point next week
here we have Scot Brompton I don't think
Epstein killed himself but I hope you do
you puffy face - piece of [ __ ] yeah your
response well you know I get that a lot
but if I were puffy faced I wouldn't be
able to fit in this neck brace
okay Scott so I don't know we have to
say to that but maybe we'll get a
follow-up tweet I don't think we're
going to a wonderful point well we have
just a few moments before the big stunt
so let's check in with our officer on
Clinton watch officer Gibbon
[Music]
well it's always let's see so now before
the big stunt let's go to the tale of
the tape the statement even has a
distinct advantage in both height and
weight meaning that if F scene wasn't
able to produce the kind of force
necessary to kill himself
Stephen may in fact be able to we will
certainly see how this affects the
outcome of tonight's event Stephen I
believe it's time for you to go and
prepare for the stunts and any last
thoughts I probably should have done
that before you had me read those
useless tweets that's what I was
planning on doing but I do want to say
too that the number on there is wrong in
the tail of the tape it's uh it's 219
out I put on some lbs but happens to the
best of us
duly noted please alright so mister can
even is approaching the set we do have
trained paramedics standing by and again
that number folks that we are shooting
for is 55 kilograms we will be measuring
at the neck as well as the tension of
the rope and it looks like he is being
fitted with a heart monitor getting that
all set to go we have the replica again
of the orange bedsheets that will be
wrapped around mr. can evens neck this
again in line with exactly what the
exactly what mr. Epstein would have
experienced we have the cell here and
the the sheet is about to be placed
around mr. Cooney vans neck but first
his pupils are being checked there all
right and again we will be measuring for
55 kilograms 55 kilograms we'll be
testing at the neck and on the tension
of the rope all right waiting for the
go-ahead from mr. Knievel himself all
set all right all right and we have to
go ahead everyone it is go time again 55
kilograms is what we will be looking for
on the rope
and at the neck he is leaning we have 22
at the rope we have let's see 228 22 on
the roof okay
we're good we're getting the signal to
stop we're getting this signal sorry
something went wrong what do we have on
the rope on the Rope the Rope is
kilogram Jude we're good I'm able to
cheese okay so one thing I want to I
want to note um this is the most
important measurement audio wave but
this is probably the least accurate
device that we have so this isn't
because the compression of the neck is
going to be dispersed around the neck
the number is going to be lower than
this monitor right here directly on the
cord so you'll notice that the numbers
significantly lower at the neck
significantly higher at the court the
real live number is probably between
those two but even then leaning well we
got to 22 kilograms okay I'm gonna try
this again and I think I think that I
can actually hold on one second I think
I can actually get this pretty close in
the spirit of being fair-minded I think
I can get this pretty close I think okay
all right mr. Eddings appears to be
ready waiting for the signal from all
right and we have the signal all set to
go we have at muster can even believe in
again again this is go time putting his
foot against the bed he's pushing we
have 16.1 at the neck 37 at the neck 38
on the rope 38 on out of 23 as a high on
the neck we have and we are shooting for
55 kilograms we are not even close 41 is
the peak what can you stop 41 in the
rope what do we have on the neck okay
hi 23 kilograms on the neck floor t3 on
the rope which is the best that we've
had I don't know if you guys could see
how it's pressing up against the bed of
course I probably have more friction on
a plywood panel here than you would have
in a prison we got pretty close I want
to explore every option here and and do
everything I can to see if we can hit
this number and I actually I do think
that I could probably
this number if if I really push it I see
a little bit of time to catch my breath
oh that was 44 44 and 22 on the rope
okay 22 on the neck alright so on the
neck that's not even close
no not even what the rope was close the
rope was close so the real number is
probably somewhere in the 30s yes
okay which means you're still alive all
right we have this eight we about
everything the safety mechanisms that we
need to do
Oh - okay good good all right all right
let's get let's get the meter set let me
know when we're good I'm gonna go for
one last try we're ladies named mr.
Kennedy nice going for one last try we
are all set to go and we have the signal
as mr. keen leans we are looking for a
mr. Krown was rolling mr. dressed by the
McGann the high on that was 62 which is
far beyond what is necessary to fracture
the neck cartilage mr. Crowder again has
collapsed he appears to be okay mr.
Khattar appears to be he is requesting
to be checked in the pupils sixty two
point nine on the rope my
goodness we are testing the limits here
mr. Knievel approaching now okay hold on
audio wait oh look everyone felt so
alive I have felt more alive but this uh
it's painful huh painful but I don't
think I would suicide it
I miss you're gonna mean there appears
to have been a lot of commotion over
there what do you think went wrong okay
please please okay what were you asking
oh I'm gonna get this off they're gonna
take my helmet thank you yes there
appears to have been a lot of commotion
what what do you think went wrong um
good question I'm still a little fuzzy I
think a better question is what went
right I seemed like everything kind of
went wrong there the meter was a
maladjusted two pounds initially and
that's what we were getting I thought
there was too much of a discrepancy
we're cut we were kind of expecting it
to be not as heavy on the neck because
of course there wouldn't be as much from
the compression heavier on the cord I
heard those first numbers out there I
panic I thought that we had a
calibration wrong it just turns out to
warn them reset to pounds so that went
wrong and I've had to question some life
decisions that have led me to this point
audio wait well mr. can even the viewers
have to know do you believe that Jeffrey
Epstein could have killed himself oh boy
that's a loaded question well I'll say
this if everyone watching what we really
set out to achieve tonight was to
hopefully show you a real-world scenario
where what we've been told about the
Jeffrey Epstein death doesn't seem to
have been entirely accurate
it'd certainly be even like we didn't
even talk about the hyoid bone but we
passed that really easily could have
done that without the neck brace that's
obviously that's not the number that
people should be concerned about what we
set out to prove was that people who are
skeptical at all doesn't mean that
you're a crazy conspiracy theorist I
think your criticisms are valid and we
wanted to put on a show hopefully give
you the ability to draw your own
conclusions and give you one hell of a
discount which you know we have offered
tonight with the promo code Epstein at
lateral credit comma slash mug Club and
you
you're you're signing up tonight
continues to fund episodes like this I'm
really just buying time because I've had
to think it through
I will say this I will say this in the
spirit of trying to be fair and as
objective as possible if Jeffrey Epstein
had been able to fashion a rope from
bedsheets which takes approximately 9 to
15 minutes going completely unnoticed in
his cell and if he were able to achieve
the exact right angle and have somebody
wheelbarrow him in his cell potentially
a cellmate and if you were able to do
that and snap his neck before he passes
out as that only takes you know about 3
to 5 seconds as we know considering the
tension and all the guards fell asleep I
think it is I think it could be possible
it could be possible if all of those
conditions are met and those conditions
would need to be met I was trying with
everything I had by myself
that wasn't to let that number I do
think that in being objective it is it
is a possibility as to whether it's the
most likely scenario people will have to
people have to decide for themselves
well there you have it folks perhaps
we'll never know what really happened
that fateful night that's it for us
again be sure to tweet using the hashtag
Epstein didn't kill himself and go to
louder with Crowder dot-com slash mug
club and enter promo code Epstein for
$20 off thank you for joining us and
good night I say one thing so we don't
we did it I love you I love you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]